all speaking of talent that got rolling
if Jayhawks in the house
I know it's pronounced Christian Brown
right but we're going to say wrong
because of the
strength that you displayed uh take us
into your mentality but it's tough for
me to sit here at Tar Heel next
time
go ahead all right look on the on the
biggest scene NBA Finals get the
opportunity to play some more minutes
um what was your mentality going into
this one yeah just make the most of my
opportunities obviously it's a big game
uh we need to bounce back and we didn't
do what we're supposed to I'm at home so
you need to bounce back and I got a
couple opportunities obviously Nicola
made it really easy on me when I was in
there when you say you
um you know we missed on a lot of
switches we messed up a lot of things on
defense and that's not who we are that's
not how we got here so it's got to
protect home court and do what we do and
be us I mean obviously they're going to
do what they do and they're going to
make their adjustments just being here
BS and we know that if we if we play our
best ball then they can't beat us you
know a lot has been made about you know
coach Foster out of Miami Heat and what
he's done with his team
talk to us about what coach Malone has
done for you and your team and how he's
guided all of you through this season
and then through the postseason yeah I
mean he stayed consistent um you know
coach Moe's one of the most competitive
people I've been around he gets the best
out of everybody just because our
competitive he is so being honest all
year um and you know in practice
whatever it is just staying honest and
you know that's how we created our
habits that's how we got here so both of
them obviously are great coaches and put
their teams in the best position but
coach Mo's been great and he's just one
of the most competitive people I've been
how did that change tell us about this
chain what what's this chain thing y'all
doing there give out the chain what
what's that all about yeah I mean it's
just uh and who made that up it's like a
football thing yeah I think it just gets
NBA players to play defense to be honest
with you during the regular season so uh
it just goes the best defensive player
and today it went to the team like I
said we took care of business and that's
what we have to do every game yeah I
don't get no money for it just to change
not no money no money no don't all year
when you were playing did you know that
you were prepping for this did you know
you'd be performing this bigger stage
you know they would call your number
where you get your your teammates
confidence your coaches confidence
performed right now yeah I mean that's
part of the part of the season that's
what it is to build their trust that's
my job to come in here and just make me
look as trustworthy to them as possible
and I think that as a team we're
building up for this to put ourselves in
this position so we had the same goal
you know we all wanted to be here um so
I just had to be as ready as possible
and those guys like I said they make it
really easy on me Nicola and Jamal they
put me in the right position so all I
got to do is go out there and be me and
play hard and you know they make it easy
you said Nicola and Jamal right they had
20 assists he'd had just 22 assists we
always talk about the Joker's ability to
pass but this is the third straight game
where Jamal has had 10 or more assists
you think that's like an underrated part
of his game playing with him yeah I mean
Mall's tough um he's you know getting a
lot of attention from the defense and
they're a great defensive team so he's
getting off the ball when he's supposed
to and making everybody's life easier so
Nicola does it every game and so does
Jamal but whenever Jamal needs a score
he scores I mean whenever he needs to
pass he passes so I think it's under the
part of this game for sure so now you
have two you have day off come back
Friday the emphasis today
tomorrow will be what get some rest and
do the same thing we did and we're
trying to come here and steal two games
like I said we didn't do our job at home
so we got to come here and steal two
games and that's you know that's the
plan uh play a lot like we did today
there's still some things we can clean
up and they're going to make adjustments
but we got to make adjustments too so
get some rest come back in here and do
the same thing but good luck and we love
the way you play I appreciate it he got
the boy next door look but he got some
dogging
he moves
now for sure flexing the muscle seventh
grade from the field Christian Brown
thank you for stopping by
oh hold up hold up here you go looking
Brown do for you
taking flights to Miami I will break you